à à
Xin
chào các bạn
đã có một ông điểm danh Nhanh thế á
à à
ờ ờ bởi vì hôm nay chị nói qua về tài
liệu và mình cũng chẳng có gì tâm sự lắm
này ra là hôm nay mình ngon hơn muộn có
là bạn hãy cứ nghĩ là có thể mình nghỉ
đấy
Ờ
vẫn có tâm sự đây nhờ chủ yếu Hôm nay và
mình vẫn đang đội phải dùng từ đang đợi
bởi vì có nhiều bạn Tôi tin là mấy bạn
hôm trước vẫn chưa kịp nằm trong tài
liệu đâu có nhiều bạn hôm trước còn đang
bảo là em không liên lạc được với đồng
đội
nên để ở trước mắt thì đang tranh thủ
của mỗi năm hay sáu người gì đó mình lại
tâm sự một tí đã đâm Đông đây một tí thì
mình sẽ bắt đầu trả lời câu hỏi nhé
đã xông vào hôm nay thật à Tôi không
biết là có kéo hơn 1 tiếng không kiểm
tra tài liệu mấy ông chỉ cần kiểm tra
nước qua cái là biết được nhưng mà
và Tí tôi cho là tôi vẫn sẽ phải
làm mẫu một cái phân tích Chức năng
Thường mấy ông này mấy ông chảnh mắc
size hôm trước thì tôi để trong bể ông
tự tự nghĩ chưa vã Nếu hôm nay kiểu gì
tội phải làm mẫu một cái không ạ và mẫu
từ đầu em cô ấy một cái gì đó tính năng
khó là Ngạn 2 tính năng đi tính năng về
giỏ hàng Ngạn đoạt rồi à
sự thay đổi số lượng sản phẩm trong giỏ
hàng này và nghĩa thêm một sản phẩm và
dầu phanh ấy thêm một sản phẩm giỏ hàng
và đặt Hà đấy hai tính năng đấy thử xem
là các bạn thấy
Ừ thế thế nào
Lần Đầu tiên cứ xem tâm sự thì đã nhé
are you
Ừ Ừ
nghe cái này khá hay nếu không có thử
nghe đi xong rồi tôi sẽ dịch lại cho
người ông sau nhé
anh trực tuyến
chị chưa có người triển anywhere thì các
bạn thi đua cái món này UC
sẽ Nhưng tôi thấy mình eguchi rất sạch
Scarlet Rose Kappa made It's not the
second with của Festival events in the
weakest live Square enix of nights I
miss you show tlive bexi ukas love each
other thấy quanh để ukas
anh nói trễ vào đây nè
phần is not connected with us every days
Dream it's just not repeat the best
suited intensity and like in such a
Ừ cái vừa rồi nói một cái hay nói giờ
chiều đi tập gim không ạ thì tập thể ít
tập thể hình Nếu mà kiểu đi ngày một
ngày hai thì sẽ chẳng cảm thấy cái gì cả
nhưng mà nếu chúng ta vẫn kiên trì mà
chúng ta không từ bỏ nếu mà vẫn tiếp tục
là thì thì không chắc chắn một ngày nào
đó không thấy thằng cụ thể một ngày
không ạ nhưng mà giới sản a mình và họ
đang càng ngày càng cậu vào form lại
stress in two chép ngoại và phong kiểu
dáng chuẩn hơn có thử thứ đúng ạ Và thậm
chí là chúng ta phải bỏ 12 ngày mà người
ăn vặt cũng được không Anh còn gì cả ý
nghĩa Lực cái cái mục đích của cái à
Ừ ok cái nó câu buổi phỏng vấn vừa rồi
Nó là kiểu ông ấy nói về
Connspeed Nó là kiểu sự kiên định sự
kiểu cần và cái quan trọng Đấy
mình nghĩ là cái quan trọng nhất nó có
niềm tin không ạ ạ ạ
cho nó giống như là kiểu học lập trình
này thôi thật là ngay từ hồi đầu mới học
thì đúng à chẳng ai hiểu nói một pha là
thích ngay cả trừ khi thần tượng anh ở
đấy thôi tôi bảo hộ đầu tôi thích làm
hacker hơn thích làm cái trang web bán
hàng thử ngay cho tôi gọi thứ nhất là
kiểu lỡ đóng tiền rồi Học thì học thứ
hai là cũng có niềm tin gì đó Bởi vì
thầy của tôi tôi có biết nói với mấy ông
chưa Nhưng thầy đâu là một trong những
người thầy rất là giỏi
đấy đó tôi rất là nể thể lấy
thầy của tôi lên kiểu dạng là
dạy ít thì à dậy bình thường ấy nhiều
người sẽ chê đấy bởi vì à Tôi từng nói
thầy có rất thích kiểu mất tích
thầy vào thầy còn thích hay buôn dưa lê
nữa nhưng mà cười câu chuyện Thầy đều
gương có ăn ý nó nhá Thế mà nói chung
nhà một buổi dậy có thấy đúng như này
thầy sẽ ngồi
gọi là áo kiểu theo Ngữ Văn học thì nó
là mở bài gián tiếp không thấy mở bài
gián tiếp một tiếng đồng hồ đã Sau đó gì
đôi khi lạc luôn hả đề không biết hôm
mày học gì thật sau đó thì thầy sẽ dạy
cho 15 đến 30 phút thôi Tại xong ra bài
tập trong mấy ông rồi xài biến mất
Ừ
thì ở trường Trần tôi thì nó là trường
nghề cái này nha Ai có cái máy tính
laptop Ai có máy tính trước mặt mày tính
của trường vẫn chưa được rồi Alo em thì
xông vào thấy mất tích thế nhiều ông sẽ
hiểu bọn mày lên chơi cái thứ chẳng muốn
làm bài tập chưa có làm bài tập xong
chán ngồi chơi thôi Cứ làm gì đó cũng
không ông nào bảo về đâu nhưng mà kiểu
lần như mấy ông ấy xác định là kìa đến
học một tí rồi chơi nhiều đấy Được đấy
tôi thì ngồi đấy Tôi từng nói rồi tôi là
kiểu khác thôi kéo làm bài xong thì tôi
sẽ ngồi nghĩ về tập nâng cao xong rồi
những câu sau hoặc thắc mắc cái gì tôi
sẽ cố đi tìm bằng được thầy hỏi thầy có
thể ngồi quán trà đá ở dưới hoặc là thầy
ngồi trong phòng giáo viên để ngồi bán
ngồi đá test nhưng mà kiểu Dĩnh bị tôi
gọi
đấy thì
Ừ
nếu mà quay lại cách dạy của thầy cách
dạy của thầy là để bọn tôi tự giác và
chủ yếu thấy không ép buộc cái gì cả em
để cái thứ nhất thứ hai đó là thầy thầy
luôn cố nói
Ừ cái cái vừa những cái buổi vừa rồi là
những bộ ra bài tập
còn những cái buổi về đoán thấy trúc
liên tục thầy Thúc và thầy động không
ảnh động viên em thấy nó liên tục về cái
ngày mà mình sẽ đi thực tập và nói Nói
chung là thầy nói với thằng ngoài rất
nhiều
anh cũng giống mấy ông đa cấp khẳng định
dùng mấy ông đa cấp
nếu đã cấp huyện nói hẳn là tương lai
màu hồng còn thấy không Nói tướng lại
màu hồng thấy nói kiểu tương lai rồi Mấy
em có thể sẽ làm được cái này sẽ em được
cái kia sống ở dưới Nói mua loa kể
chuyện thấy có dẫn chứng rất là hay rất
nhiều người các thứ mấy sau mang về sau
mày mới tôi cũng được làm một trong
những ví dụ về thầy kể cho sinh viên
đấy thì
Ừ cái cách thầy nói làm chúng tôi không
hề sợ việc đi ngược tập cũng không hề sợ
về đồ án bởi vì chúng tôi nghe những
điều đấy hàng ngày từ lúc bắt đầu học
rồi thế nên là nó bị hằn sâu vào tiềm
thức để ông hình dầu không là thứ nhất
là niềm tin vào việc của mình sẽ làm
được cái gì đó mình không sợ nữa Mình
nghe nó hàng ngày
Ừ nếu không thì dù ngày nào đến thầy nó
cũng nó kể với nó ngày nào đến thầy cũng
kể từ giờ trở đi là thứ về sau mới tôi
Bọn tôi sẵn sàng đăng ký đi thực tập
thật nhiều ông bây giờ mấy ông có kiến
thức hẳn hoi mấy ông ngại đi thực tập vì
À thầy cô mấy ông chơi rồi nhắc đến vụ
đấy Nói thẳng như thế Nói thẳng như thế
thật đấy bởi vì tôi thấy rất nhiều thầy
cô ở trường đại học không hề nhắc đến vụ
đi là tầm cho đến khi đến khi ở gần ra
dưỡng mới bắt đầu mới dục sinh viên yêu
thật không nhắc nó mỗi ngày cá giờ sử
thì nó sẽ không có tinh thần chuẩn bị
được cái điều đấy
ừ đấy thế nào tôi nè ở thích thầy tôi
dậy ngày nào nhắc này nó hằn sâu tên
nước Bọn tôi ngày nào kiểu tỷ lệ đi làm
của bọn tôi tôi bảo rồi tỷ lệ đi làm của
tôi hơn bảy mươi phần trăm đương nhiên
là 70 phần trăm đăng ký làm đúng nhàng
thôi nhưng mà còn về sau thì rơi rụng
thì không quan tâm bỏ tôi không có trồng
cây rồi đấy việc trường không bán tận
hơn một năm hai năm để ngồi kiểm tra
Sinh viên còn đi làm hay không Không có
tâm nhưng mà lúc bảo quản thực tập là
bọn tôi tỷ lệ hơn 70 năm mấy trường đại
học của mấy ông có khẳng định đều được
điều này ông 50 phần trăm còn không
khẳng định được thì khóa Trường Tộ 1 bây
giờ kể tôi khẳng định nhé đang là đại
học nha còn chưa người không biết chứ
nghề với chị nhưng mà thế mà rõ ràng là
cái đầu vào của sinh viên trường tôi
phải chịu phải hiểu là
A gọi là
Trượt đại học không có ý định học đại
học cố để trốn đi nghĩa vụ quân sự đủ
thể loại gần như thế chẳng có ông nào để
đỗ rất nhiều đại học xong Dựng Yên Hưng
ấn vào đây
khi nãy nói thẳng là nhiều ô có bị lừa
đấy Đấy thế mà Mấy ông ấy vẫn còn dám đi
thực tập được thì chứng tỏ là mấy ông ấy
hơn mấy ông ở điểm gì
đã hơn mấy ông không phải là trình độ
không chắc chắn nó hành trình độ chẳng
qua là hơn mấy ông là niềm tin đơn giản
thế thôi người ta còn niềm tin ra không
hẳn niềm tin ở làm được nhưng họ không
sợ bạn họ niềm tin là họ muốn gửi họ
muốn thử làm gì đó họ tin là họ cái này
là không nên nỗi khó thế
chi nhánh thì thỏa mãn á tắt wi-fi khác
nhé Tôi mới đổi từ mới đổi cục màu đen
tôi đăng ký gói ạ wi-fi cao nhất của hộ
gia đình thường dẫn của 12 người không
như người chưa tôi không ngủ ra tôi thấy
em nó cũng chênh lệch giá lắm rồi Chị
tôi hơi bị chi tiền và những cái mà tôi
cảm thấy à Nó đám tôi chịu đôi khi hơi
mạnh tay gì à
ờ ờ đấy Nói chung à cái vừa rồi thì tôi
muốn nói cho mấy ông làm với ông thực ra
không nên sợ gì cả
Ừ thôi trước tôi thường ngồi mà tôi chưa
đi làm này nhớ hồi ngay mà hồi là tôi
chưa đi làm đi làm giảng viên thôi tôi
đã hơn người khác là một đi và tôi tự
tin tự ti hơn những người khác ngồi đây
tôi đúng kiểu chỉ Mạnh mồm chứ được là
tôi không có nghĩa gì trong tay cả Đúng
nghĩa không có tiền không có sự nhiệt và
vật nhỏ tôi vẫn tự tin hơn người khác
đấy Đấy do thôi đôi khi ăn được người
khác những điểm đấy
chúng tôi không phải làm một cái gì đó
Khi mà chúng ta đã nghĩ là mình sẽ thua
cả đúng không giống như tỏ tình con gái
vậy cứ nghĩ em sẽ thật sẽ rất tình cờ
khi mình hết Mình thật cái bài toán này
niềm tin khi ở nó nếu mà các bạn tham
gia đa cấp bị nó sẽ có đề cập rõ hơn đó
là về vụ
có rất nhiều cái trường hợp với từng đọc
giống như kiểu ở một bác sĩ
Anh bảo bảo bình bệnh nhân ung thư giai
đoạn cuối là đây là thuốc giải anh cần
uống mỗi ngày ra để cấm đường thôi nhưng
mà người kia có niềm tin mãnh liệt là họ
sẽ khỏi thật và họ lạc quan hơn yêu đời
hơn và đúng là họ hỏi thật cái đấy nghe
nó hơi điêu Nhưng tôi đã từng tin cả đấy
tin ở chứ không phải tin là việc là mình
tin sẽ khỏi bệnh nó sẽ gọi bệnh thật cái
đấy vấn đề về tâm linh hơn hơn một tí
nhưng mà ý tôi ấy đó nó tin là nên sống
cuộc sống kiểu dạng mà mình luôn lạc
quan luôn yêu đời luôn kiểu tâm trạng
mình rất là ổn thì nó sẽ chắc chắn ở cái
sức khỏe của ông sẽ tốt hơn so với người
lúc nào đi công an bởi người có ăn người
ta sẽ chẳng ăn uống gì cả tháng sinh
hoạt đấy mà chẳng ra ngoài chẳng hạn thì
sẽ đi con cuộc sống đúng không họ sẽ làm
những điều dại dột thì đã trả nợ sức
khỏe học có tốt hay không Họ nghĩ họ sắp
chết thì gọi đi tập thể dục hô khi họ
sắp chết họ có muốn hiểu họ chỉ muốn phá
thêm với Họ tận hưởng đến cửa phá họ có
giữ sức khỏe không khớp chỉ người lạc
quan thì họ sẽ tốt hơn rồi là ngon thì
mấy ông nên thế
anh làm sao để được tay rạng dai 8
bây giờ bình đẳng thôi mình chủ động
thôi mình không hẳn là chủ động yêu cậu
là anh nuôi bạn em đi
Ngay hợp với say quá vội vã con nhưng mà
chủ động ở đây lắm chị ạ
tôi tôi thấy bọn cả mấy bạn nữ có cách
chủ động riêng mà Lượn lờ trước mặt anh
ấy ngờ lần này chú ý Tình Cờ Gặp tình cờ
Nhưng mà thực ra là chú ý vẫn Văn Nhiều
cái mà Nghĩa đám chỉ rồi mình tự tạo cơ
hội cho chính mình thôi bây giờ xử mình
cứ ngồi trong nhà cả ngày rồi đội có anh
hot boy Hàn Xẻng nào đó đến tận nhà gõ
cửa
đấy thì chả Anh ấy đi tìm bạn cả thành
phố mà Đúng không mấy ổng mới các bạn
phải chủ động nhé Đúng không Không phải
chủ động được đăng sao tốt thì yên tâm
Tôi không thích cái điều ấy là con gái
là có người yêu đang sơn tút thả thính
quá say luôn nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà kiểu và
nói chung là tôi Tôi thích Khả Ngân Tớ
thích mấy bạn nữ mà biểu đôi khi ở đó
chỉ khác biệt ở thường xuyên bình luận
gì được kiểu dáng năng động Đấy Bình
luận ở nhiều nhóm này có sự thứ mình có
thể gây sự mình có thể ghi mình cái đấy
cũng như là cái việc là tôi không thích
việc ẩn like một cái gì đó tôi phải ấn
ha Thả tim thương thước nó sẽ đặc biệt
hơn vì nó số ít so với những người ở ẩn
hạ like từ thể like đưa vô cảm vãi Anh
ở đây cá nhân đôi ở Nga kiểu Tôi thấy
kiểu các bạn hoàn toàn là kiểu dùng
Chính cái mạng xã hội tại tương tác cũng
như ở trên tường mình cũng không nên
chia sẻ những cái đôi khi mình có buồn
thì mình chia sẻ một mình để mình ngày
này năm sau sẽ lại là mình đã từng tâm
trạng là thôi hoặc cùng Đăng Tôi đã nghĩ
thôi đừng có đang nhìn cái Sorry trong
một ngày thì Huế và chia sẻ cái nói
chung hài hước một tí biết đâu có người
cùng chung sở thích ông ạ Đừng Nói Chia
sẻ tâm trạng nhiều
ừ ừ
rất
nhiều bạn nữ cần sự quan tâm lắm không
Anh thề Dạo này bạn trước em từng tán
bây giờ cứ toàn inbox anh kể về bản thân
này bạn ý Ừ chắc bạn em bị thừa hưởng
tình cảm
hỏi ông mà bạn thân khác rồi
ừ nóng hổi Bây giờ tôi thấy Bấm cái này
đúng từ thiện luôn đấy rõ là họ đọc họ
cũng như cảm xúc hơn thế họ bế tắc lắm
thôi Có ai đấy Con không hiểu không biết
ấn cái gì đâu mà nói đấy hả Thôi lại đi
xa quá Thôi tôi xin phép nói nốt về cái
này
Ừ cái này tự nhiên tôi xem ở Tôi không
biết được là với tôi mở cái anh có giấy
bản quyền không những đầu tiên mà ông
biết được câu chuyện tình Romeo với lén
không nhỉ
từ khóa thứ hai hoặc thứ hai Chắc là
tháng 3 tháng 3 sẽ có ờ ờ
Ê mấy ông biết chuyện tình Romeo chỗ em
gái chưa đầy không nên ngoan đúng không
ở tuổi sẽ cố biết nói lấy ngoan đấy nó
có liên quan đến cái chết luôn đó chính
là nó về niềm tin
ừ ừ tôi nhớ không lầm cái kết của cái
đấy nghe này xin lỗi khi mà nhiều ông
chưa xem nhiều tôi tôi chỉ biết ngồi kế
thôi Nó 22 người chết vì nhau đúng không
để cái kết
đầu tiên là
ở
đầu tiên là một đứa một người giả vờ tự
tử vì bài so với kia tưởng để chết thật
tự tử theo đầu tiên us mình như là dòng
tự tử
hôn mê thì gì đó sợ nó thì Romeo thay
thế chết thôi cùng us thấy người mình
chết là lại tự tử thật chết cũng không
Cả hai con chết
Nếu kết là như thế nhưng mà từ đấy chúng
ta chích chỉ ra được cái gì của tình yêu
là bất diệt và Vân không ra rồi mình tin
và tình yêu tìm gì đó mua quá nhiều quá
Nhấn lỗi mình hi sinh bản thân mình dùng
ai nói vụ là Romeo như 17 còn us thì
Nhưng mày mới 13 14 gì đấy cái đấy nó
hơi tội đồ thì nghĩa tình gà nha anh
người ta nếu ở đấy nghĩa đôi khi chúng
ta tin một cái gì đó chúng ta thể làm
được nhiều điều lệ gồm như thế Tôi không
yêu cầu mấy ông tin và tôi mức độ cậu
phải làm điều gì đó dạy họ đến như thế Ừ
đi mà Mấy ông nên a a
gọi nhắn tin tôi với Tôi không hại với
ông ấy nhất là mấy ông lên à
tự lo sự nghiệp mình Nếu giả sử Nếu năng
xem của tôi cũng phải để cho vui không
phải để Bóc mẽ với ông cũng nên Kiểu Học
hành cái tự tế một tí đúng đại lại như
thế
cho nên hả Cảm Xúc Chứ tôi thấy mấy ông
đừng mua rồi dùng cái lại tôi tôi xóa
sửa cái này thì nếu được tôi sẽ cài tiện
ích để mà nó bấm bấm tự động Thả tim cái
gì đó nó tiện hơn bấm like nữa à
Ờ Ờ thôi tiếp sang những câu hỏi nhé Hôm
trước có một bạn hỏi là em muốn nó
ai cập nhật thường xuyên cho một ngày
định kỳ một lần hai ạ xóa định kỳ 1 ngày
1 lần
khi mà con vẫn chí vài lần thì cả đấy
khái niệm nó như là nó khái niệm đấy sẽ
golf đưa TP để làm chỉ là các bạn sẽ tạo
một cái file để xử lý một cái tính năng
gì đó giống như vừa rồi bảo xoáy nóng
hoặc sau đó thì sẽ vào cái phần server
server các bạn Huê lộ hết sinh ngày con
sẽ vô gì đó nó sẽ có cái khái niệm rót
như thế này để mà các bạn cấu hình vào
là nó chạy định kỳ trong vòng bao lâu
tầm 1 ngày 1 lần vào mấy giờ thì gì đó
rất nhiều Tại chế độ để trịch đấy để mà
cứ cái con server nó sẽ chạy 2424 mà nó
không bắt thế là nó sẽ kiểm tra cứ đến
đúng giờ đấy nó sẽ chạy cái file pp đấy
Từ xử lý để thế nên đấy khái niệm golf
các bạn thể tìm hiểu khái niệm này để mà
về sau các bạn làm ra sự giống như hồi
trước tôi là ngon checkbox rằng ăn cứ
728 độ sáng tôi sẽ tự động 3 mở
a cho các bạn ảnh gái xinh Nhật Bản thức
dậy đi anh ảnh cái này xong rồi mấy ông
thấy bấm vào xem thêm rồi lúc đấy mới
bắt đầu gửi cho mảng cũng không Lúc đầu
sẽ luôn bây giờ sáng sẽ gửi một cái xinh
rồi Thích vãi Nhưng mà nhiều vọng cũng
nhắn tin trở lại là tại sao mày nhắn anh
cái trong yếu tao à
Anh cho em hỏi à
Ừ cái này khái niệm này Thực ra là mấy
cái khái niệm này tôi nghĩ là tất cả các
bạn nên theo google thay vì cứ hỏi tôi
vì tôi không phải từ điển sống nếu mà
nhỏ tôi vẫn để lại câu hò này vừa tôi
theo theo như tôi thì Dung bây giờ đấy
thì như tôi đã nói là lập trình viên
mình
nên làm cái sản phẩm gì đó Có hữu ích
một tí không gọi một sản phẩm mà không
ai dùng được nó vô dụng ấy thì mới ông
phải tìm hiểu xem chị trường cho sự cần
gì người dùng bây giờ thực sự cần gì nó
trí ngã business lôgic này bị gì Nghĩa
lý tích này nó cả phân tích thị trường
phân tích xem mà kiểu bây giờ thực sự
người dùng cần gì phải business này nó
đôi khi nhiều người dễ bị nhầm là khái
niệm là kiểu là nó liên quan đến kinh
doanh và sản phẩm phải kinh doanh hiểu
không đôi khi là chút chúng ta làm sản
phẩm miễn phí được Nhưng mà thực sự là
người dùng thực sự cần gì thì nó chính
là bị nó mới là khái niệm duy nhất còn
nếu mà về kinh doanh khái niệm khác nữa
cơ là các bạn còn phải học Bên trí nhà
thiết kế bên kinh tế đấy dân kinh tế làm
chứ không phải là bạn là không phải dân
công nghệ làm
à Còn cái dân công nghệ để tìm hiểu xem
thực sự người dùng cần gì chị cái đấy
đâu phải kinh doanh đau đúng thì đúng
nghĩa là mấy ông có thể tìm hiểu về cái
đấy cũng được Nếu hôm ấy ông muốn làm
quen show 2 mày không muốn tự tạo ra
được sản phẩm đi đó nhiều người biết đến
sử về sau tôi thử cao tục nóng ước mơ là
sự tôi bảo tôi muốn làm trên ngoài phim
Vì Locker cũng tương đối tầm
chục nghìn người biết đến ở rồi mình có
trăm nghìn người đông quá và sản phẩm
tôi về sau tôi làm ra Mày Cái trang web
kiểu trang web nhà máy sinh này hay tiện
ích gì đó thì thực ra đến lúc đấy
cũng cần một lượng người đó biết đến gọi
một vài cái sản phẩm để đời ông ạ cơ thế
chả gù là phải lên tên mình nằm chắn hai
tháng 3 chứ gọi đưa Cha vô tên mình trôi
sư đâu rồi a
tiếp theo
ở Iraq lúc nào phải dùng với gd các bạn
này hơi bị
Anh chưa hiểu rõ cái này lắm Nhất là cái
A giác theo mình nhớ không lầm thì nó nó
là hàm của thư viện degree những cái sản
mà phải cài thư viện này thì mới có hàng
này nhưng mà còn để trả lời sau hơn một
tí thì ý bạn này có thể là bây giờ em
muốn gọi đến cái file khác để lấy thông
tin hay là đẩy thông tin trong khai khác
để thông tin hơn trong cách khác thì
phải cài jre và phải dùng giác à đấy thì
không Thực ra là do Swift mà đã có sẵn
cái khái niệm các bạn sẽ biết khái niệm
của nó đây mình cho các bạn xem thực là
mấy lần mình bảo ở bên Network ẩn bên
Fake và nó ích hết rồi mà khái niệm để
mà khi mà đẩy dữ liệu anh sang hay là
lấy dữ liệu từ cái trang web khác về như
thế bằng ra suýt bị nó sẽ Khái niệm và
xh pro đấy từ cái mình không nhớ nó cái
tắt cái gì đâu nhưng mà nhưng mà đấy thì
và cái thằng Isaac này chẳng qua là nó
viết cái ít hơn trong 1 dễ hiểu hơn thôi
chứ người ta là các bạn không cần phải
cài thú viện không cần dùng hàng và Iraq
mà có bạn dùng hàm xhr của HG Switch
thuần cũng được rồi đấy các bạn Thể tra
rồi đấy
khi hạ Jack của Real
Tôi không ngờ lắm đâu ạ
ở không mà ông cứ đọc đi nó lại ít hơn ở
đây này là qua nó gọi thế thôi
à à à giác này cứ tắt nữa à Đúng ra phải
thì biết tắt cái này nhưng thực ra nó là
xr nó vẫn là ít hay đây thôi con ý tôi
đang nói cái Isaac này này nó là hàm của
Iraq thấy là Hà mã Zip của Ji chứ còn ra
Swift thì nó cái này cái này nói hàm ý
Tháo đồ này ờ
là con gà dek để mà ông gọi mình cái
Honda giáp bình thường ấy là liệu e kiểu
như này thì hà mã giấc mấy thớt này nó
là của ra của di thư viện của geely ông
hiểu không đấy Con không thì ông gọi
tưởng như này nói
chắc nó nó viết tắt của cái này để lấy
thông tin như thủy bằng ra Swift thôi
đúng không và là Xuka nó là
nó thực là bạn chất nó ít hơn rồi
em chưa ạ
Ừ ok ờ
ở
cái đoạn này thì
Anh bảo là đôi cái vào lui nút để cái
đoạn mà nhập thay đổi số lượng sản phẩm
do hàng ấy xong rồi để người dùng cứ sửa
xong rồi em sắp ít thì có nguy hiểm
không Thực ra là
cái này thì khi mà để người dùng nhập nó
vẫn luôn có cái gì đó nguy hiểm rồi đấy
do mình phải vaj bằng cả khăn và cả Bác
đúng không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi Bây giờ không ai dùng zin nữa
bởi vì thư viện đấy nó khá là cũ rồi và
có nhiều hàm thừa quá anh ra người ta
bây giờ dùng thuần họ dùng hẳn Facebook
khác
Ừ cái hình cái này chỉ còn là các bạn
phải và biết cả bên Khoan và bác en mỗi
cái khi mà người dùng nhập cái gì đó
đúng không
Ừ thế thôi Bây giờ tôi
kiểm tra 8 rưỡi rồi Hai tội Có vẻ lâu
nhưng mà bây giờ tôi kiểm tra nhanh cái
à
khi bắt gặp xoay nhắn nhầm
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu muốn đi làm mà máy em thì nên học
chuyên sâu về bất kỳ ngôn ngữ lập trình
nào cũng được
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà đừng có ngôn ngữ lập trình
mà kiểu
kén kén người
tại sao từ kén người kén trình độ chỉ ra
thế Tại sao bởi vì với p2 ở zava hay là
phí thon mấy cái ngôn ngữ còn tương đối
gọi là phổ biến bây giờ thì ra không cần
phải có năm kinh nghiệm thì các bạn vẫn
thể suy nhược tập được vẫn có người hỗ
trợ có nhớ là sửa các bạn kén leo cậu Lọ
chơi xin sharp-cee + +
xi này Đấy chẳng hạn
chỉ có vài ngôn ngữ nữa cơ thì nó rất
kén bởi vì nó chỉ nó không đào tạo các
bạn ở công ty nên nó toàn đòi hỏi những
người có 5 cái nghiệm rồi thận thậm chí
phải 34 năm kinh nghiệm 5 năm kinh
nghiệm Thế nên à ở các bạn đang hỏi ngày
chắc chắn như các bạn Chuyện năm kinh
nghiệm thì các bạn nên chọn ngôn ngữ nào
nó đang phổ biến để người ta có thể đào
tạo các bạn thì ra các bạn chỉ cần làm
thí nghiệm gì người ta sẽ đến đào tạo
cái người ta chỉ con ngon giọng với cái
thái độ làm việc này và cam kết là sẽ
làm người ta trưng về người ta đào tạo
xong rồi té này
và tinh thần làm việc và vân vân tư duy
thực ra cũng một phần thôi có tư duy ai
cũng ai cũng thích ai cũng nửa thích nữa
không một cái ông Thông minh thông minh
quá nhưng đôi khi họ không đào tạo được
Kiểu gì hết thương mình vừa thôi
anh làm sao để nặn có 5 thí nghiệm đến
xíu + Giả sử bây giờ mấy ông làm có kinh
nghiệm đấy thì mấy ông chỉ có tự làm một
cái dự án gì đó xong rồi
chia sẻ cho cộng đồng nhiều người dùng
xô người đóng góp gì những cái mã nguồn
mấy cái mã nguồn mở ấy phổ biến các thứ
thứ để có được chứng nhận gì đó chứ Giờ
chẳng ai tuyển ông đâu
ở mỗi lần hơn dữ liệu nhấn F5 nhìn nó
thêm cái nữa
ờ ờ đúng rồi Nếu mà sử các bạn nhảy nhảy
sang cái phone xử lý rồi các bạn em Nam
lại nói thêm về do các bạn lên các bạn
lên điều hướng quay lại chứ Tránh việc
là để màn hình chán Ở người dùng vẫn còn
ở đấy người dùng trên F5 lại thêm đúng
không
anh không Mẹ không biết hysweep làm đâu
em à Ok giờ mình à mà không biết có nhóm
nào làm xong tài liệu chưa biết bạn vứt
ở đâu luôn cơ
á Vừa nãy tôi nhớ Tôi có update rồi
hai nhóm nhóm nào làm xong tài liệu ở
nhà để tôi xem nhỉ Không thì tôi cứ chữ
mẫu một cái đã nhá Tôi trợ mẫu gạch đi à
à
à à là tôi chữa luôn ở trong cái á bộ
trước đi
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ tôi ở đây tôi chuyên mẫu vespa có một
tí Speed vào ơi tôi chuyên về ạ Wow từ
ra còn nhiều hơn nên mấy ông đừng có hỏi
tôi về bên phần này lắng hỏi tôi về Wow
này
t là leo này thì được hoặc hỏi tôi về tư
duy Nói chung nhà kiểu về à
định hướng nghề nghiệp cho tôi chả được
anh còn hỏi với ngôn ngữ 2 ở thuật toán
thì đô thị được không trả được
ở
nhà ông bác Hồ đang bảo vệ tôi là có
những bạn bỏ
chịu Vợ nói thế thì tôi không biết lên
là người bạn anh cười gì cũng không ép
rồi các bạn đấy
À mà tôi sẽ ăn thử phân tích mẫu thêm
hai tính năng lượng nhé á Ừ
thì giới thứ ba Bây giờ mày không có
tiện cái mấy ông làm cốt rồi nên mày ông
có thể mở cái file code lên để xe Tôi sẽ
thử thử cho mấy ông nhé đầu tiên thì như
tôi đã bảo thì mỗi tính năng đây là một
trang Đây là cái đoạn này nó đang một
trang rồi tôi sẽ ăn cho nên tôi
copy cái này
à à
ở
nhà bây giờ đây
mã số VTC tôi sẽ làm tính năng là thay
thêm sản phẩm nào giao hàng ạ ạ
Ừ
từ các mô tả nó giống hết rồi
mấy ông mấy ông copy sang mà Mấy ông
muốn nó chỉ lấy mỗi chữ thôi mấy ông có
thể cắn cho shipper hãy vì con chuẩn về
nhé
xe khách đã đăng nhập thể nào ạ
à à ấn vào nút
có
thêm đã giao hàng à
cách sản phẩm ngon giới sản phẩm
ờ ờ đầu vào tất cả mã sản phẩm nhé
trình tự xử lý
thứ hai tôi khỏi nhiều bạn sẽ bảo hơi
khó chịu ở phía tao nó sẽ lấy luôn từ
cái này nhưng cho gà Các bạn thấy trình
được Mình nhớ có thể chỉnh được nó có
cái vụ reset reset này
thì các bạn phải chuyên word vào tôi
khẳng định hôm nay công ty tôi còn vừa
ra tôi ngồi lại viết tài liệu sau thôi
cảm hệ tôi kiêm hơi nhiều việc phải trên
công ty
à nho Tôi từng nói tôi đa-zi-năng một tí
ờ ờ Tôi sẽ mở code đây lại Mày xem lại
nha ở nhà mẹ ông không còn nhớ
về giá tổ không ngờ làm đâu Nhà tôi cứ
cho mà em xem lại cốt nữa Ở đây có thêm
sẵn phạt
bóng đá
We are they Won City ở không nó là ác từ
card về auto cad đây Gì đây Nếu chỉ cần
ở đầu tiên là mấy ông sẽ tạm bộ chai các
đi cho các hơi phức tạp một tí đây mình
sẽ là tên là mẫu phim mở phiên đúng
không
mở tiền
Ừ xin gọi phiên đăng nhập
khi mở phiên xử lý đi
tiếp theo à
à à
cách
kiểm tra mã sản phẩm
tiền lên à
à à
chồng nhỉ báo lỗi
là
điều hướng quay lại và báo lỗi
cho
nó biết cách để bấm nhảy này nhanh như
nào ẩn Corona cam chôn ở cái mụ cái phím
Ừ thì móc nhọn đấy hoặc nhọn hoặc gỗ mấy
này theo tôi bảo tôi chưa nuốt mà à
ở đó sau đó thì kiểm tra trong
sinh viên trọ hàng
đã tồn tại
mã sản phẩm
ngày chưa đúng về văn xuôi không ạ à
ở đây Nếu có thì làm gì đúng không
có mày có ấy sẽ
có
phải cái này nó ra à sẽ đi bên trăm nữa
Ý là nếu không chữa đi nếu không không
đổi chưa có đi Ờ
thì mình sẽ
đã kết nối cơ sở liệu đúng không
thịt heo là
lấy thông tin
sản phẩm theo Mã
Ừ rồi Tiếp theo là
truyền thông tin
sản phẩm vào phiên giỏ hàng
theo mã sản phẩm
cụ thể mình có thể mở ngoặc ra lại cụ
thể dụng là tên này
ảnh này
giá này
số lượng để mặc định là một này cái mấy
ông thầy văn xuôi nó sẽ như là văn xuôi
nó như là đến từ đây ra cốc này không
phải người bại rồi bây giờ Khánh hơi
ngược lại đi
có gì sẽ làm gì có chị em giảm là à Đăng
số lượng sản phải
trong phiên giỏ hàng theo mã sản phẩm
trắng da
A11
ờ ờ
Ừ thế thôi rồi điều hướng quay lại
Ừ thế là cái điều hướng quay lại được
hay không cần gửi nó đầu ra nếu người
Xóa đi ở đây Đúng rồi
à à
họ điều hướng
anh quay lại và thông báo thành công mà
đẩy sẽ thế
Ê
mày không có thể
ở cái đoạn Mày thử ta đoạn đầu ra nó hơi
điệp khúc một tí
Anh nhớ mà
ờ ờ
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này là giống kiểu mã Dạ
Giống thế cơ mà
tra cứu scale này nó về thôi mà thế này
để mà có tài liệu ngay để mấy ông nhìn
vào đây mấy ông cốt được mà đúng không
Ê mày không có thể nói ghi cũng mơ hồ
hơn một tí được không sao bởi vì hồi mà
hồi mà béo làm tài liệu này mấy hôm
trước biết cốt Nhưng mấy ông phải ghi rõ
phần thấy quý và thực ra phải kiểm tra
cái gì liệu kiểm tra không được cái gì
đó như này vẫn Vân này chả cua vừa rồi
tôi bảo kiểm tra hết ở trên này lưu ý
đây không cần ứng được tùy Nếu không
hiểu không Nếu có thể kiểm tra thêm là
là bắt buộc phải đăng nhập này cái gì đó
lại được không Sao đấy mấy ông méo hình
dung được cái tôi Vợ vừa viết tài liệu
mà Ê mấy ông nhìn cái này Cái quan trọng
là mẹ không nhìn vào đây mà không có cốt
lại được không có tin là Tuấn nhìn ở đây
tôi Cốt lại được cái cái cái file vừa
rồi đúng không ạ
Ừ ông thấy nhìn nào có cốt không ạ Tôi
thấy không khó lắm nữa đúng ạ thì đấy
Đấy là cách viết tài liệu biết tài liệu
là sao cho mà kéo mình người khác bạc và
người ta vẫn này làm cái tính nam đợi
đấy mấy cách viết thể hiện chưa mà biết
rượu trong mình ông hiểu cho mình không
đọc không ạ Đây quan trọng như thế
Ừ Ok chị ạ tại thì mày ông nhìn đây tham
khảo để mà viết tài liệu nếu mà về tự
tin để chắc phải hơn nữa mấy ông chơi mà
làm chất điện mà đúng không
Nhìn có cái nhìn tham khảo thôi
em
hẹn chứ sao bay đây nhỉ à
a Control Center tự Nhật hàng ngày để
sánh 4 kiến
anh gửi tin nóng bị lác lác đác đi
ô
hay bị nhảy sang 4
à à
Ừ ok
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia vừa nói đúng hôm
trước tội nó đấy Đó là nếu là sử mà các
bạn thấy là nó phát sinh em vấn đề Đúng
là các bạn phải có lại sửa liệu có nhiều
người bị lười vụ này rất nhiều lập trình
viên bị lừa vụ này và đúng là nó như thế
thật rất nhiều công ty tài liệu nó bị
chậm hơn bị cách xa so với cốt rất nhiều
của vì Cốt về sau cứ sửa mình chỉ nhớ
giờ mới có thôi mình không cần nhờ loại
vật liệu thành ra nó như điểm mà những
người sau mà khi vào nhìn vào cốt của
mấy ông chẳng hiểu gì cả nghìn tài liệu
rõ hơn Tài liệu bị lỗi thời rồi
Ừ để một công ty làm việc không chuyên
nghiệp làm doanh nghiệp lắm và hơi bị
công ty cho tôi hiện tại đúng như thế
này người mới vào được Có nhận chẳng
hiểu gì cả nếu mà công ty tôi đang thiếu
người thiếu và người viết tài liệu này
của chấp nhận thế nên tôi bảo tôi đang
ngồi cái dữ liệu này đây nhưng thực ra
thường có một ông ty bên công ty đổi mới
tuyển mobii PG lý và phân tích phân tích
thị trường này Phân tích Xem cần làm
tính năng gì đấy sẽ muốn viết tài liệu
như này quá Nhìn thì là những cái thì
Năm Cũ ngồi viết là tài liệu được là cần
có đầu và là gì đầu ra gì Cần xử lý
những nào cần phải lưu ý cái gì đó để
sao chọn người sau
người sau nhớ là người sau biết được đã
làm những gì rồi biết được là thực ra
toàn bộ cái file dài dòng hơn 1.000 dòng
này bản chất nó làm là gì nó đã cần lưu
ý những cái gì Và thậm chí ghi thêm tài
liệu để mà
Ừ để mà kiểu người người sao vẫn thấy
tiếp tục cúc quan trọng như thế
đề tài liệu này mà Mày mới là một trong
những cái quan trọng
anh Bởi vì ông còn tài liệu này ông còn
thể Cốt lại được cả cái phần mềm kia
giống hình dung đó
chẳng phải là kiểu mấy ông chị trăm nó
cốt thì thực ra là về sau mình cũng
không phải là người viết tài liệu rồi
Anh vừa rồi đó là nhiệm vụ Bie hãy nhiệm
vụ người khác đấy chẳng hạn nó ngon thì
cũng không cần mày lo gần đây này Nhưng
mấy ông cũng phải biết cách đọc tài liệu
đúng không có dậm chết chị tôi Tôi đang
dậy yêu mày ông rất nhiều việc mà từ
việc thiết kế đã tự thử về sau đôi khi
mấy ông có được động ở đâu nó cũng làm
bác em mà Mấy ông làm đâu khi ở sẽ lập
trình viên thôi mà em không làm phân
tích không làm gì cả đúng không Anh chỉ
cắm đầu người làm kiểu người ta giao gì
làm đấy chứ không phải một phân tích
kiểu như này chúng tôi đã hướng dẫn ông
để cho mấy ông cần bạn Chích cái công
việc nào hơn giả sử cái xong nữa ông
thích làm thiết kế đã gió bay hơn thầy
viết tại biển thích hơn rồi ạ nóng lạnh
tại vì họ họ cũng chả thích gì được thấy
việc gì cũng khó thôi không thích nữa
đấy nhưng mà tôi đang chị ông quy trình
làm một cái sản phẩm Nó phải từ đầu đến
cuối nói như thế nào và nói phải phải
chuẩn là như thế nào nó để không biết
mấy ông thích em mấy ông về sau biết cái
này xong với ông về sau thì chửi lại với
thằng bia thì mình một làm tài liệu chán
như thế nào ạ
Ừ tôi tân mấy thời gian mới tham gia ít
Công ty bao nhiêu ạ tôi công ty tôi đang
liên kết với rất nhiều bên đổi Tab bên
nước ngoài bỏ viết tài liệu Chán kinh
khủng api mà chán kinh khủng và ấy bia
của thằng Facebook cũng thế tài liệu của
thằng Facebook thế của Zalo từng cái nồi
dẫn nhờ hàng dvi và nó vẫn đều và nó vẫn
tài liệu rất cũ Liên là cậu vẫn sống
hàng chửi của nó gửi hiện tôi khẳng định
tôi viết tài liệu tốt hơn bọn nó à
Ừ đúng rồi vietlott này tester đôi khi
mày nhìn là tài liệu mày test những thực
là từ đấy Được ra có nhiều tranh như thế
này nó thể ra đời nó kết hợp cả của cả
ấy bia rồi cả tính năng để test cái
Trang đấy là Trang
sợ nhớ mi
thời trang đời đã Trang
ờ ờ ờ
Hai Thái Cực này tôi sẽ
ở đây Hình như đây Hình như đây
cài đặt Vợ chăm lo của mình nhé vừa có
thể test được cái tay nhé
xe tải miễn phí Sino lại chồng như thế
này lại sample nha
đam mê như thế nào ngủ đây là xanh vừa
viết tài liệu Vừa bấm cái để test luôn
tính năng đấy luôn đấy Đấy nó kết hợp cả
hai nó sẽ lấy từ toàn bộ những cái ý
nghĩa hay ông đã cấu hình các những thứ
để tạo ra rất nhiều thằng mới được Đăng
Dung
em yên tâm là có rất nhiều cái thằng nó
hỗ trợ cho người dùng rồi Quan trọng là
mày không có cục than này không thôi
ngon
ở đâu nhá thăm ví dụ thôi nghỉ đậu xanh
anh có hai cực kiểu vừa đọc mà xong rồi
vợ biết tài liệu này Vừa bấm cái A
khoa học vệ sinh
à à
10 cái này để cấu hình nói ý
xe tải Tôi trông đúng cái
Đợi tí nhé người cho đúng cái
ở bên tôi đang làm nhé Đợi tôi một tí
cho mấy ông xem cho mày không biết
ý
cho làm Liên kết để cho thằng bên này
anh gửi tin nhắn đợi tí
à à
đi thay vì nhớ không lầm nó được được
bạn Mimi rồi
ờ ờ anh chút nữa nhé đây hai cũng được
tạo bởi kia ai đó vậy nhìn nhé
ở bờ trang tài liệu này sẽ hướng dẫn cậu
cần bấm vào cái gì cần bấm vào cái gì đó
như này Và thậm chí à Đây này test api
này nó sẽ truyền thông tin vào như này
xuống bé ông còn chai hết là nó xảy ra
hết toàn bộ dữ liệu ra đây đây đây là
Trang nó cho Android là tài liệu và kết
hợp với cả api đến bến test này
lấy làm ăn chuyên nghiệp phải thế
thằng vừa rồi cũng tạm chuyên nghiệp tôi
không còn chuyên nghiệp lắm luôn nó vẫn
còn cái đều riêng hỏi nhưng mà đấy thì
mày ông sẽ thấy ta liệu nó phải kiểu
kiểu như thế dễ hiểu hẳn giao diện web
chứ không phải word trò này nữa rồi Bấm
vào để test được luôn đúng không Thế mới
gọi là thiên nhiên là thế về sau được
trị viên mình mấy kiểu testo biết dễ
dùng đúng không vân vân
ờ ờ
cho tôi không biết nói mấy cái đấy mày
Ông ấy ông ấy có tải không em à để tương
lai nó phải như hệ với ông hình dung
việc là trên làm việc chuyên nghiệp nóc
nhà là thành ạ
rất là
ừ ừ
a hoàn xử lý
đặt hàng ạ
à à
anh không biết dùng từ nhà nữa luôn Tạm
phải thế ấn nút
em
đặt hàng à
ạ
sau khi đã
thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng ở nào ạ
xe tải trôi lên chơi như thế này nó hợp
lý hơn
3 cách
Ừ ok đây đâu vào thì không có cái gì cả
Không có cái gì cả
bắt đầu vào Có bạn bảo nó lấy từ phiên
này có thể thứ thì phải ở dưới này mới
xử lý này
họ đậu xanh
Ừ ông xã này bị ạ
Ở
đây là ở
à à
anh mãi Mở này lên thôi
à mình làm xong hết rồi mà mình mình xem
này nhanh thôi
Hả Đây đây à
Em có đầu vào có như thế có
ở công ty nhanh
à à
Anh
tên người nhận à
chỉ
số điện thoại người nhận
địa chỉ người nhận
ờ ờ
khi mở phiên đặt mở phiên
khi
mở kết nối cơ sở dữ liệu
nó
lấy thông tin
giỏ hàng từ viễn
cách
tính tổng
số tiền
Ừ Từ
tất cả a Tính tổng tiền đi tính tổng
tiền tất cả sản phẩm
trong giỏ
Ừ
đấy mã
người dùng từ phiễn đăng nhập
à à
cho thêm hóa đơn
khi
mở ngoặc là ghi rõ là đây lại mã người
dùng à
đi tìm người nhận đấy đấy tuổi bởi vì rõ
ra mấy ông sẽ thấy
nó sẽ dài nha
nếu anh sẽ bảo là em thả cốt còn hơn
nhưng mà rõ ràng là cái này là để cho
người khác làm ảnh cái gì đó vợ nữa
trạng thái
mặc định là không nhận ạ
có tổng tiến à
từ hôm trước có bạn bảo là khi mình
Insert này xong có thể dùng luôn hàng xe
xmax ID cũng cả hai a sẽ lại Insert ID
khá hay
Ừ tôi không biết để hàm đấy tôi lại phải
sẽ rexmac lại sao nữa
cách
lấy mã đơn vừa thêm để thêm vào hóa đơn
chi tiết
tiếng Anh à
Tự nhiên lại nhớ đến các bạn sinh viên
trường trường tôi trưởng trường trước
tôi dậy bây giờ thì các bạn ấy đang phải
làm toàn bộ bằng tiếng Anh thuyết trình
bằng tiếng Anh nữa khóc khi mà rõ ràng
mình các bạn thực ra đầu vào rồi bảo thủ
ra đầu gà Chúng tôi không phải tốt nên
thực ra để mà người học tiếng Anh nhiều
bạn đã bị mất gốc sẵn rồi đấy này ra
Kiểu cái đấy Đúng kéo anh càng khiến các
bạn ấy mạnh hơn tôi cảm thấy hoàn toàn
không cần thiết khi mà rõ ra là có những
cái tiếng Anh chuyên ngành này là quá đủ
thôi quá đủ rồi không cần lại làm hay gì
cả
ô ồ
vì thế mà họ lâm chi tiết
em
chạy vòng lọc ạ
anh không Cái này phải là ế
à à
em
chạy vòng lặp
từng sản phẩm
để thêm vào hóa đơn chi tiết mã hóa đơn
mã sản phẩm à
vì
số lượng đã đạt
trong giỏ
à à
anh xóa bỏ hả
họ phiến
À thế à Sửa bạn không
không có kiểm tra gì cả thì chỉ có
trường hợp này thôi
Ồ thông báo đặt hàng thành công nương
Ngô Vân lưu ý ở đây là gì tùy các bạn
đấy đấy Tôi vừa rồi làm người Ông thầy
đó à cốt có phải dài nhưng thực ra nó
cũng chỉ có đúng ngắn gọn ngay ngắn gọn
thì phải gỗ hơi dài dòng một tí nhưng mà
béo hoàn toàn nhìn vào đây mày không thể
Cốt lại được cái cái pha này đúng không
ạ giấy đây đây cách để mà cách làm tài
liệu thế này là tôi anh chị yêu cầu mấy
ông làm chứ Phân tích tầm mười gái thôi
mà mai hả mày không có cốt rồi Nếu nhìn
lại để làm thì ra nó cũng dễ
chứ thực ra nếu mà chuẩn ấy là có bao
nhiêu tình năng từng tính năng bé thôi
Kiểu Đăng nhập đăng xuất này thêm sản
phẩm này Xóa sản phẩm sửa sản phẩm cứ
một tính năng đấy là một cái bảng như
thế này
anh đúng không ạ bộ phim cứ có bao nhiêu
file cốt xử lý của mấy ông là đồng nghĩa
với có bấy nhiều cái phân tích tài liệu
phân tích tính năng đơn giản ấy thôi Có
mỗi cái trang kiểu hiển thị toàn bộ tất
cả sản phẩm đấy cũng là một tính năng và
đấy cũng cũng là gì gì đó rồi ông ạ
em thấy thìa tay ở tôi tạm chưa chấm
Tôi chưa biết cái nhóm Các bạn chuẩn bị
này chưa này trở để thứ năm tới chấm mận
để lại tạm lùi thêm tí nhóm nào cần chữa
sớm thì có thể nhắn tin cho tôi chữa giờ
sự xong rồi hình nhìn tôi tôi biết tới
chữa Vừa rồi tôi ở nắp đê Hình như có
mỗi một hai nhóm mới có chỗ chưa biết
đầy đủ hay không Và hôm nay chữa không
biết là người bạn này có thể Toan không
cần phải sửa gì không nữa đừng ăn thì
cho Để Thứ năm tôi sẽ chậm như vậy thì
tôi vừa rồi tôi chữa như thế này và lưu
lại ở trên chín cái trang kia rồi mấy
ông thể xem tham khảo luôn không ạ để
mấy ông biết được là mình cần làm chuẩn
là như thế nào
vì tôi tự tin là cái khá ổn rồi không
biết có thầy cô khác dậy hay là công ty
khác là mình sẽ như nào tôi thấy được
cách viết tài liệu nhẹ khá ổn thôi cố
gắng cách trình bày thôi Nhìn thấy xinh
vậy ta và nhìn trông hơi thì gì đó Nhớ
Các bạn nhìn ở đây các bạn sẽ hoàn toàn
được cốt được này ông ạ tôi nghĩa ổn mà
Ừ dạo này sửa lại
một này
Ừ ok Tối nay
ừ ừ
Ừ cái đậu xanh
thế này bị nhảy khó chữ phết
à à
ừ ừ
ê
mông cả tôi hơi bị à
à à
em ở đâu này phải nhảy vào trong
Uh cho nó bị cầu toàn nhưng tôi đang
ngồi sữa mẹ đi xin lỗi nha
à à
Ừ ok đấy
Khi
bữa nay chắc là chỉ kết thúc tại đây thì
thôi Mày không còn thắc mắc gì không nhỉ
Anh thấy mấy ông già nói gì cả Không
biết mấy ông có mua xe mới không hay
choáng quá nhưng mà bột này cho anh chị
nhắn này thôi
Ừ vậy mai tôi còn ngồi trả lời Đông câu
câu hỏi kia kéo dài nửa tiếng ấy là tài
liệu này nó tương đối tôi thấy từ người
khó Dạo này còn những cái đoạn kia tao
không chữa với chị cứ ý mấy ông đấy Thôi
để mày ông tự làm chứ mày ông tôi chữa
cho mấy ông mấy ông sẽ giống hệt nhau
thì không có gì đáng thì đọc à Đông ạ Nó
lên khác nhau Tuy nhiên nếu để thêm Hải
trên mạng có nhiều mà
Ừ Ok
sao không thắc mắc vì sao Phượng ngày 18
cây thuốc thuế này em nghỉ đúng 9 giờ
này bạn trả bạn nhé